What up, B?
This week on Thug Notes, we flyin solo with "Jane Eyre" by Charlotte Brontë.
As a kid, Jane Eyre livin with her twisted aunt, Mrs. Reed, and her punk-ass cousins,
who ain't showin no love for my girl Jane.
After dealin with these haters for years, some righteous doc named Lloyd hooks Jane up
and convinces Mrs. Reed to send Jane away to get schooled.
But Jane ain’t bout to bounce before givin Mrs. Reed a big ol’ "f**k you."
So Jane arrives at Lowood school,
where some b*tch-ass clergyman named Brocklehurst starts hatin on my girl,
sayin she ain't nothing but a lyin trick.
But Jane’s homie Helen and a righteous teacher named Miss Temple tell Jane they got her back.
When Jane’s sista, Helen, dies from consumption and Miss Temple chunks deuces outta Lowood,
Jane bails and starts hustlin as a governess up in Thornfield Hall,
where some uptown gangsta named Edward Rochester be livin.
Once Jane meets Eddie, they start chillin on the reg.
But meanwhile, some mysterious sh*t starts going down at Thornfield:
crazy laughin, somebody startin a fire in Eddie’s room, and one of the house guests gettin shanked.
Later, crusty Aunt Reed sends the word that she bout to kick the bucket.
Now, Jane’s forgiveness don’t quit — so she goes back home and nurses this ho.
When Jane rolls back to Thornfield, Edward proposes, and they plan on shackin up together.
Sh*t gets ridiculous durin the ceremony, when some playa-hater named Mason
say that Edward is already married.
Seems Edward’s wife, Bertha, went wack in the head, and she the one who been wreckin sh*t in Eddie's crib.
Jane be straight trippin about Edward actin like a pimp, and so she peaces out of Thornfield.
Now Jane be all cashed out, askin for help, til some playas named Rivers take her in —
turns out they be her cousins!
And when Jane’s Uncle John dies, he leaves her some mad cash!
Now, Jane got C-notes by da stack, homie.
Then, Jane starts jonesing for her boy Edward,
so she drops in on Thornfield and sees that the whole place has been burnt down!
Turns out, Bertha’s twisted ass dun blazed the whole place, then killed herself.
Damn!
Not only that, but Eddie dun lost his sight and his hand during the scuffle.
But Jane keeps it real and says, “Hey, blood, I don’t care if you ugly as sh*t. I love you anyway.”
Then, they get married and have a little G of they own.
Aight son, if you a hustla, you know that the cribs where Jane been stayin at
symbolize all the bullsh*t women had to deal with in Victorian patriarchal society:
oppression wit Auntie Reed, starvation at Lowood, madness at Thornfield,
and indifference when kickin it wit da Rivers.
But it ain’t til we hear bout Eddie's crazy biddy, Bertha, that Brontë starts doin it big.
So, if you forever thuggin, you gotta check out how Brontë makin Bertha Jane’s shadow double, playboy.
All the slangin and bangin that this hoochie be doin up in Eddie’s turf
representin all that rage Jane been keepin inside since her days with Auntie Reed.
In fact, it don’t get no realer than Bertha, since she the only one who fightin the power that dun f**ked her over.
Cuz on the real, who wouldn’t wanna start tearin sh*t up if you got sold to some stranger for a bit o' cash?
So, what my girl Charlotte tryna say bout traditional society is:
why can’t women express they desires without bein called crazy?
Yo, you best get in da zone and listen to this here motif, blood.
Brontë be stackin images of nature
to show how Jane’s amped-up emotions go way beyond what’s acceptable for women to be feeling.
For example, when Rochester proposes to Jane, it starts stormin all up in there for two straight hours.
It’s like she been keepin her feelings in for so long, sh*t goes wild when she's finally able to let it out.
You can check how Brontë extends this nature motif to my boy, Eddie, too.
After he proposes to Jane, lightin strikes a big-ass tree, splittin it in half.
The two halves of the tree representin Eddie’s divided loyalties —
one to his passion for Jane, and the other  to the law and the church, who ain’t got no love for they union.
Brontë also spittin truth about the state of the Victorian woman through the red room Jane gets locked up in.
Now, this room full of secret compartments and bloody images, which be associated wit dat oohie!
So, dat red room really be all the isolation and hatin
dat women gotta deal wit during their development into adulthood.
Ya heard? Yo, thanks for chillin wit yo boy,
Sparky. Hit subscribe, and I'll see yo ass next week!